في الملف النووي الايراني قال وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي انه اكد لرئيس هيئه الاركان
الامريكيه مارك ميلي الذي يزور اسرائيل
اهميه استمرار العمل لمنع ايران من امتلاك
اسلحه نوويه وكانت وزاره الدفاع
الاسرائيليه قد قالت ان رئيس هيئه الاركان
ان التقى نظيره الامريكي وانه سيلتقي وزير
الدفاع ومسؤولين امنيين اسرائيليين واوضحت
ان المباحثات تناولت التحديات الامنيه
الاقليميه والتنسيق المشترك للدفاع ضد
التهديدات الاقليميه
ياتي ذلك بينما قال الجيش الاسرائيلي انه
انهى مناورات بريه مشتركه مع قوات من
المارينز الامريكيه تابعه للقياده الوسطى
واضاف ان تلك المناورات حاكت تعزيز
التعاون المشترك بين القوات البريه
للجيشين الى جانب سلاح المدفعيه وشملت
المناورات لاول مره تنسيق ضربه جويه
محتمله لمنشات نوويه ايرانيه تشارك فيها
عشرات الطائرات المقاتله والاسطول البحري
الذي شمل سفنا حربيه وغواصات وحامل
الطائرات امريكيه وصلت خصيصا الى المنطقه
من رام الله معنا مراسله الجزيره جيفارا
المدير جيفارا ماذا عن هذه المناورات
المشتركه واهم في هذه المره هذه المناوره
المشتركه تنفيذ عمليات فيما يتعلق بالجانب
الايراني
يعني المناورات متواصله لم تتوقف اوسعها
كان خلال الاسابيع الماضيه حيث شاركت فيها
سفن حربيه غواصات حاملات طائرات سواء في
صحراء النقب او في البحر الابيض
المتوسط زياره رئيس هيئه الجيوش الامريكيه
مهمه جدا بالنسبه لاسرائيل والي الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لاكثر من سبب هي بدايه
تمهيدا لزياره وزير الدفاع الامريكي الذي
سيصل على ما يبدو الاربعاء القادم الى
المنطقه وايضا الاهم هو التحضير لان
امكانيه توجيه ضربه لايران لانه مع
التقارير التي تصدر تباعا مع اقتراب
المنشات النوويه الايرانيه من التخصيب
الذي قد يصل خلال اسابيع قليله الى
امكانيه الوصول الى 90% من امكانيه انتاج
قنبله نوويه فان الان التحديات اصبحت اكبر
لماذا تحدي الان اكبر لانه في ظل ايضا
التقارير عن امكانيه تسلم ايران صواريخ اس
400 من روسيا فذلك سيكون عائق امام
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه من توجيه
ضربه للمنشات النوويه الايرانيه اذا
الولايات المتحده واسرائيل تريد العمل على
اكثر من مسار الاول تريد اسرائيل ان يكون
هناك فرض عقوبات جديده اكثر صرامه
اقتصاديه على ايران اقامه تحالف اقوى
واكبر في منطقه الشرق الاوسط من مع دول
تعتبر ايران عدو مشترك وايضا تمتين
العلاقات الاستراتيجيه العسكريه ما بين
اسرائيل والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ولكن ايضا الولايات المتحده
يعني في زياره
رئيس هيئه الاركان الاسرائيليه ايضا ملفات
اخرى الملف النووي الايراني يرى فيه
المسؤول الامريكي بانه يجب ان يبدا بتهدئه
الوضع في الضفه الغربيه ووقف التصعيد
وراينا الصفعه المدويه التي تقلقتها
اسرائيل من شريكها الامريكي بسبب احداث
حواره والامر الاخر هو عدم اجراء
التغييرات تشريعيه في القوانين لان ذلك
سيكون عائق ايضا امام الحوار الاستراتيجي
العسكري بين اسرائيل والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه شكرا جزيلا لك